B oh hi John Stamos on the show today
John Stamos is here and just is John
Stamos in love with me everyone's no
impossible I feel like I he did text me
and he was like that was maybe my
favorite interview so he's gone on a
couple other podcasts ignore those
actually unsubscribe from them
and sorry that's such a funny directive
to be like guys like subscribe also
unsubscribe from Bad friends unsubscribe
that would be that's such a funny you
guys we can resubscribe later I just
think it would be funny if Bobby Lee and
Santino woke up one day and just had
like half a million less Subs we can do
it again I just can you guys help me out
on this prank anyway why am I talking
about them those hoes do not belong in
this intro um so John Stamos is here
he's amazing he's hilarious super
interesting conversation lots of hot
gossip actually uh before before we get
to Stamos uh just FYI if you want to
come see me live please do you know that
I just live for your approval uh June
28th I'm going to be in eie Pennsylvania
at the Warner Theater I'm going to be in
Las Vegas July 6 2024 that's Fourth of
July weekend let's celebrate the birth
of America and the fact that I didn't
die in child birth I'm going to be in
Edmonton Canada Alberta Canada The Great
Outdoors Comedy Festival that's July
17th with Burke ker also I have a new
standup special out so I did a a special
nflix um about a year ago called jokes
this is one that I couldn't do on
Netflix because I yell about trans
people and say all kinds of things I'm
not supposed to say so we did it with
of.tv Whitney that's only fans
TV section so you know we can get away
with pretty much anything but don't
worry there you're not going to get a
invoice from Legal Zoom from your
ex-wife saying that you're losing
custody to your kids because you're on
only fan you're not on only fans there's
a subscription side and then there is
the TV side
of.tv Whitney and it's free specials
called mouthy enjoy here's John Stamos
who just gets hotter as he gets
older I can't deal with you being this
good look I mean that will save for the
thing cuz I please like let's go are we
rolling we have our first clip are we
rolling first C and today is the day
that we reveal the father of my child
serious live on the
podcast is it me what's happening over
there sorry I'm just trying to get is
that is it is that uncomfortable do
switch it's so comfortable whne how are
you now how many shows have you done how
many episodes of this
25 and this is the first time I've been
on I've asked you before also if you
want to do this we'll do this what I
will go through our text go ahead I'll
go through our text you asked me and
then you canceled then you wanted me to
do something with those two funny ladies
I do two photo or two photo of you my
screen saver um I do have two numbers
for you I don't think nobody cares no I
think everybody cares let's just go
through all of our text about you I
think I was I'm so excited about you
that you're pregnant than now you sent
me a video do you remember and it was so
it was sort of out of the oh we have to
talk about that weird doctor we went to
you look like a movie you look like like
Sophia Loren or something or what is
this what is happen I'm not kidding I
had let's talk about when we first met
you love this story what's the story you
love this story The Bob sagot roast yeah
you came into the room and they said I
was a writer this was my first no I had
written on the flavor flave roast the
year before yeah and then I was a writer
on The Bob Sager roast yeah and they
said come in and meet Stamos right yeah
and I thought which by the way you're
the first person they ever invited me to
come in and like pitch to the celebrity
really so I was already like very
nervous you walked in I go oh my God who
is that you you look like the hot Muppet
on in the band you know that girl
because I did have Bangs She Bangs and I
was like really thick bangs I was like
she can't be funny she's so hot and then
you were the PO you were even you're as
funny as hot as as you were hot well
thank you and now you're so
successful and um that was a real that
roast was maybe my favorite ever it's a
good one huh my favorite ever do you
remember what jokes you wrote for me
they were really oh gosh I don't I I do
I think I remember just killing myself
on that roast writing a lot of really
good jokes and then just being leveled
by Norm set being the funniest I've ever
heard Norm McDonald did corny jokes on
purpose and remember during the taping I
mean what you saw in the Final Cut was
like five minutes that went on for like
18 minutes and we were we were the only
ones laughing I think Bob was he's dead
now so I won't say he was dying cuz see
that happened another time but he was
crying laughing and the most I I've
never felt more joy them watching Bob
wipe tears from his eyes with Norm going
you're not over the hill not in the car
you drive just just the dumbest jokes
nobody got it in the audience they were
and it just kept going and then we all
started laughing on stage then you guys
it that was the best roast you know why
because first of all it had you uh
second of all it um people were friends
they were friends they were all Bob's
friends it wasn't like rando's coming up
there doing you know Bob actually had
friends did you know Bob from when we
did the special did you know before I
knew Bob from the obviously just from
being a fan and stand up I saw him he
would come to The Comedy Store every now
and then some he would come to the
Improv and then uh when I work with Jeff
Ross on the flavor flave roast I think
we like hung out a couple times I
remember the first time I hang out with
Bob he made me of course laugh harder
than I've ever laughed and it's not even
a good joke I almost like don't even
want
to tell this story Bob because it makes
it seem like you're a hacky comic but
some he could do the dumbest and make it
so funny and we were this is how long
ago it was because of the device I'm
about to reference we were at the Palm
or the what's the one that has all the
actor head shots
and um you know like right as soon as
dinner's over everyone gets on their
phone and everyone just kind of does
like this and he had ordered a like a
Sunday with fruit or some on it and he
grabbed a Blackberry and he's like I
have to send some emails for my
Blackberry and
he no one really noticed it like cuz we
were all and then we look over and he's
committed to the bit so hard that it's
like all mushed up in his hand it's just
like he's covered in blackberry and it
was just like just I was I like had to
go for a walk I was laughing so hard he
he I think that was Dave's joke by the
way KU um but Bob Bob's dead so we can
say yeah bobitt to it harder May if we
don't talk about him I know he he'll
complain um I gotta say he really also
made me
um at a time whenever I am like oh is
you can't joke about this or we
shouldn't or when like the internet gets
to me or whatever I remember we were
there's nothing you can't joke there's
just nothing you cannot joke about in
general we were at the bowy once having
dinner and I ordered this
lasagna thing and right as I was about
to take a bite of it he just went hey
don't eat my sister right yeah too soon
his sister had a skin disase that was
just and I remember just like like
that's Bob that's Bob that's how he got
through it you know and and and the rest
of us maybe had a different and find
your people if you can't laugh at the
same these aren't your people do know
what I mean I'm sure other people would
have been horrified but that's like oh
we're just family we vibrate like this
totally he I asked him to to host my
dad's funeral and he got up and said
tonight's specials are cake and cock and
we're out of cake my mom was and then he
was doing like you know circumcision
callari jokes he's a Jew and all stuff
and but we needed it at that moment he's
a guy look we didn't like each other in
the beginning very much we that you talk
about that in the book a little bit
that's fascinating I didn't know how to
the two hardest chapters turned out to
be the Full House stuff because I know
how much it means to people and I I just
I had a love haate relationship with it
and and Bob and I had a hate haate
relationship with each other at at the
um at Bob's funeral you were there we
were getting out of the car remember to
go over to the the actual um casket and
everything and I just remember worrying
Chappelle and John Mayer were going to
drop that casket oh yeah this is when
Chappelle wasn't in great shape no I was
carrying it too and I had a foot problem
and Dave had something and as I get out
of the car uh Sherry his his uh his
first wife comes running up to me she
hugging me she goes Bob loved you so
much he also hated you he was so jealous
of you you know so and you know when our
three sisters so his sister got
Scleroderma and he spent the rest of his
life you know we've been to a lot of his
events um trying to find a raise money
for a cure Dave's sister had this
terrible cancer and then my sister got a
brain tumor tumor right and it was the
three of us then all of a sudden we're
not just you know castmates we were
brothers grieving our sisters and that's
what really brought me and Bob together
we were like okay enough of this bull
let's put our petty aside and let's uh
learn from each other I I it took me a
while to say that what a genius he was
but it did now but was he also by the
way on the show also doing funniest
videos simultaneously yeah and that was
good because once he got that it was
like okay you're doing that show and he
felt better about himself he wasn't as
jealous of me and we weren't I think
it's like really hard to understand when
someone's that successful and that funny
that they could be insecure well yeah
you know and this is like a big thing of
reading your book I was like oh you can
look like you and be as successful as
you and like feel insecure that's like
mindblowing Yeah I wanted to focus in on
some of the relatable stuff like that
versus you know play with the Beach Boys
met a million people yeah but Bob Bob
was the most insecure right what killed
me and maybe you can relate to this is
like the amount of Love That poured out
for people for from for him like haven't
seen that since Princess Diana or
something and I'm not even and he didn't
know it because you couldn't say Bob
you're great or Bob you're talented
because he wasn't he he didn't have
seven Netflix specials and he wasn't
playing you know the Forum or whatever
it is in his mind he was never quite
successful or or funny and it's
interesting because it's like I also see
a lot of people that didn't accomplish
half of what Bob accomplished and aren't
half as funny as him but they think
they're like the sh you know I think
Comics it's either you know it's the
sort of like arrogant super narcissistic
mediocre people are really great people
who think that they suck and I think
part of that is is part of like what
drives us you know is that too intense
very hot oh it's hot or bad it's great I
don't know how to make coffee I don't
even understand what the draw is about
it yeah I don't even think it's that
good why you drinking it because I think
I'm supposed to why do you look so great
I don't what do you why do you I'm
telling you I've always had a crush on
you I remember being at Warner I
remember the room we were in I Remember
You Walking In Ray James I think and the
director what's his name crazy Jo G Joel
crazy Joel Joel who would love you Joel
who would um
grade the jokes with a check or a check
plus and so we would just watch him read
the Jokes which jokes are meant to be
delivered so we like can we like deliver
them for you he would just sit there and
do check check plus check I remember it
being very like I came back like Bob
asked me to host it I was like oh okay
and then when I saw some of the jokes I
can't you can't say I can't say this
baby right yeah and I I said most of
them and then at the end of the night I
was so happy because it was really fun
and then when I saw it I I went I
freaked out
I called Bob I called well I think a lot
of when I was shooting it I was clapping
back at all the all the comics there was
some great jokes I think you wrote let
me think did you write um I actually
looked for the documents of it and I had
just switched computers so I'd have to
like dig him up I was hoping to happen
Cloud they I know I can't my nudes got
leaked we can't do the cloud anymore you
did it really oh right right and you
just said you went straight on say here
they are mother that was great yeah I
had a well it was I had accidentally
uploaded
photo of my boob and then whatever took
it down and then how did you
accidentally upload picture upload it to
work I don't know if you've taken
California Edibles oh no I I first and
last time okay and what happened you and
well I had like uploaded it by accident
like I was just being an idiot in the
bathtub and like my boob was out who
cares and then I took it down someone
had screen grabbed it the day before
special came out said I think $188,000
or I'm going to sell this to a tabloid
whatever and so I just posted it was
that but that but you were you
accidentally put it on Twitter or
something or yeah I put it on like
Twitter and Instagram and all that kind
of stuff it was also was like I wasn't
going to like press chart it I was
probably just a kid you know what I mean
it was probably some I don't know I
thought you were so and so funny at that
thing I had some did you write the joke
where um uh Josh Davis walks into oh no
that was Gilbert but but I don't know
you guys wrote it Josh Davis walks into
a bar the bartender says uh hey we have
a drink named after you and John St says
you have a drink named secret fat
I don't like saying that word by the way
and I had a lot of um can we beep it or
why well I'm not a comic like said back
then you're quoting a comic I love
Comics I love the science of it I love
the math of it the way you guys you know
set up jokes and stuff and think you
would have been a comic if you weren't
so handsome no I I don't think I could I
can't remember all those words well I
think because I've been uh listening to
you obsessively on other podcasts
because I never want to ask questions
that you've already asked cuz I feel
like you so you don't have to like be a
broken record um but I was so blown away
by like that bullying story of the guy
that punched you in the car and like
that's the moment a comedian is made CU
that's when you're like I got to use
jokes to fight back I got to use jokes
to survive did you have well in my case
and I remember I got punched by this
bully because his girlfriend wanted to
go out with me and it was the beginning
of it was really interesting to write
about because it was the beginning of of
it was the first time that a girl like I
heard that a pretty girl liked me like I
was the caterpillar like turning into
the butterflies halfway or something and
I was like wow she W and I told
everybody and I was at this block party
and um I was at the dorky H party and
then down at the end of the block was
this this girl's boyfriend who was a
jock and he heard about it cuz I told
everybody and he I was in the car knock
on the window and oh hey I roll bam have
you ever been hit i' never been hit and
it was shocking and I was like oh my God
and there was there was no talk of
bullying back then or counselors or
anything no that was just recess yeah
right where did you grow up again uh DC
Virginia right my last name is cumming
so I had my fair share of of
that um and so my every I said I have to
do something I walked into the bathroom
and he wrote uh I'm gonna kill you big
nose and I thought I have to do
something I have to do something drastic
right now I have to become famous and
that's what that's what that's what
propelled me every PL so do have you had
that fascinating literally fascinating
yeah every time I got on I had it was
one moment my dad was watching Ronney
Dangerfield on TV he would watch SNL and
I couldn't get his attention and I
remember going I need to get in the Box
I need get and that was it that was your
first lesbian
experience did she say that um is your
dad still around no Mom no were they
proud of you no okay I think I know some
of the story maybe they were yeah yeah
yes and I think they were they probably
didn't know to show it but they were in
their own sort of so the bullying thing
and I and I really came to to terms with
um you know what now I'm successful I'm
going I write a book and you know I
wanted to dedicate the book to him they
said no but I did I figured he he
probably can't read so I hope he's
listening I had change his name but um
it's amazing how like a just one moment
like that can change the entire course
of your life it ate me up man it hurt so
bad for so long and I finally think
writing this book I finally let go of a
lot of stuff not just not just him so if
I saw him I'd be you know hey man you
proba should Edible Arrangements yeah I
should send him something tires
percentage of your fortune and that's
what I would tell him say hey man some
tires white maybe White Walls um I would
say thank you man because of you I've
I've I've you know propelled me to get
where I wanted to go and no hard
feelings and God bless and goodbye does
he know it was you but like is he like a
phantom limb lost in the war I still
would I said oh by the way uh I dated
you know that your girlfriend for three
years and she said you were hung like a
finch so you ass you think I'm still
bitter I'm not cock sucker hung like a
seahorse I hated it mother I mean you
know it's by the way I had a lot of like
like making fun of my last name and I
think that's part of what made me like
quick and have to defend myself you
beautiful and you still are so how did
you get around that I mean what was that
about but I as an adult 5 years ago was
really roughly bullied by someone in our
business I'll tell you who it was and it
thw Molly Kimmel Molly Kimmel you were
and and it threw me for years and I just
now kind of got over it did you have you
confronted this person no it's like I I
was like I'm not going to come forward
I'm not going to snitch on this was it
Kelly from Kelly and reges no was it
Ryan it wasn't Ryan was it a guy or a
girl uh a girl you to think about it a
girl is she on the
housewives no is
she like a bitchy tough ass woman
Caitlyn Jenner it's not Caitlyn Jenner
okay it's
a I love you she's like you stole my
face wait did I finish pring you thing
Bo you create these shows that were
successful you go on rosan remember that
that whole controversy but you H you you
were graceful through that whole thing
um and now here you your last special
was great I texted you a couple times I
was watching it with my wife we loved it
thank you and uh now you're pregnant No
One Believes Me I think I also talked
very publicly about freezing my eggs
like in a special like a couple years
ago so everyone thinks I like a Tesla or
like no everyone's like this from a
human man like it's this very odd thing
you didn't I don't know I'm very excited
what am I in for oh my God I'm so happy
for you because you know what my other
name was Billy I'm so excited for you
it's the greatest thing ever and it's
what my whole life I wanted to be
married and have a kid and I didn't
think I was going to get there you know
the Indiana Jones like with the walls
coming down and he's and people shooting
darts at him probably same with you and
he grabbed the the the the Whip and
slides under and the wall goes down just
in nick of time that's me with the wife
and kid and you with a kid but don't you
feel like I'm glad that I waited till I
was if I had done this a two years
sooner 100% yeah there's no way I could
have been a great father like you know
before I sobered up like whatever eight
nine years ago it's it t it's it I've
always wanted kids I've been around kids
forever um it's so much harder than to
be a good parent it's so much harder
than I thought but it's the most
rewarding beautiful thing is there some
weird thing where you kind of get to
redo your childhood a little bit too
like go to Disneyland like you do that
anyway on a daily basis which is so
funny I was listening to you on Chelsea
I I here's here's what I love about
Disneyland okay I know you're Disneyland
head I have two of my best friends on
the show Once Upon a Time that ABC show
play Snow White and Prince Charming so
when we go to Disneyland it's like
they're The Beatles right you know what
I mean like they dress up like it's what
they they dress up like those no just
everybody knows them it's like this
whole thing but we get to do like the
tours and stuff and one of the tour
guides told me number one at night they
let out 100 cats that go kill all the
rats and you've never heard of a problem
at Disneyland there was like the exit
through the gift shop documentary where
Banky had put in like a Guantanamo Bay
prisoner on one of them but you never
hear about shit going there's a prison
underneath there's like a whole thing
and then they have plain closed cops in
case like weirdos without kids are just
walking around and if you like really
watch you'll see someone just one man
walk up to another man and be like hey
bud we're gonna go for a little walk oh
yeah yeah they did that with Michael
Jackson I
think Michael Jackson would because I
grew up right by Disneyland and you know
my friends all my friends that I've
known forever have worked there forever
and they said he would one of the gags
was that he would get into this uh one
of the trash box ice cream boxes okay
and they took all the ice cream out and
there was a little hole and he had a
walkie-talkie and okay that that kid
over there I want to take this I'm not
kidding you you think I'm going to get
in trouble for saying that you get like
like the like the ice cream truck no it
was like a a like a rolling case and' be
in there he'd be in there with the snow
cones with eating the snow cones and um
but I mean you have you talk do you
think he we don't have to get in this
but I mean he literally I mean this is
my he also abused animals so you know
I'm like in the Exotic Animal tra he had
elephants and giraffes he built a zoo to
get kids to come right oh he didn't have
sex with the animalss wasure I they
people get mad but you know he was
whatever I I'm did you know him I didn't
know him but he called me once um and he
said hey John this is Michael Jackson I
was on U I was on ER and I played it for
everybody he said I really dig your he
wanted I bought the sign out in front of
Disneyland and he wanted it too and it
was on auction and um he he wanted that
so he said I really dig your stuff
whatever that means and he said let's go
to Disneyland someday and then I I
remember hanging up going I'm never G
like and I was playing it for all the
people on yards but wait he tried but
you have the sign yes you have it m how
much was how much was that wasn't wasn't
much it was um it was right when eBay
first started and and Disney thought oh
let's get rid of a bunch of this shit
and it's the original whole sign from
Harbor Boulevard o there's also by the
way YouTube channels of former Disney
Princesses talking about all the rules
they're not allowed to talk they're not
allowed to chew gum they're not allowed
to eat like all the stuff in character
like they get these like really serious
like makeup lessons like I'm just
obsessed with that so cool right there's
a there's a sign I have at my house that
it's like good show and bad show and the
good show is was like how you're
supposed to wear your sideburns and your
nails and everything bad shows like bad
long sideburns it's from the from the'
70s or something like that we were
shooting at Disney World with Full House
and the they were shooting a scene out
it was hot you it was Orlando and uh the
twin somebody kept messing up their
lines and there was a character one of
the twins clearly they own Disney World
now I went to Disney World with the on
the um so the car by the way didn't you
get me a coffee was that my coffee no I
was making coffee and I was like do you
want one and you said no and so I just
started drinking it I said yes well what
kind of coffee do you want well it's too
late now no I'll go get you one tell the
story and then I'll go should I just
take over no no I'm really don't don't
no we're getting your coffee John S I am
but it's it's a even if it's just
psychological do you want some of mine
you might not like it I put I put hot
honey in mine no thank you Patrick thank
you Pat thanks Pat now we can talk about
P right oh what's with the pat fucking
Pat fucking Pat I have never cared what
entrance of my house people come into
until Stamos came in the side door well
you spend you you do a whole thing in
the it's
a side so that you don't see it and then
I spent all this time like making the
house look nice and then he comes in the
side with all the I didn't see that part
I didn't see stuff so we're doing a
scene I was an in it and there's
thousands of people you know at Disney
World watching us do the scene watching
them do the scene and there's a time
limit for these characters with the
heads and the thing cuz it's very hot
yeah and the the uh minder who was with
the person going oh one more minute Joel
zwick did you know Joel zwick I know
that name famous sitcom director he
looked like a little
crab it's I need one more one more and
they did it again they screwed up why
one more and they're like they're way
over the time and the character I can't
remember boom and passed out now instead
of they can't take the head off in front
of 5,000 people watching so they drag
the poor person backstage like by their
arms like what mascot was it I can't
remember but but that's uh that's how
but they're very you know but you inside
those things is apparently incredibly
hot yeah and super inhumane for them to
be in there right have you ever there is
a moment though when you've gone to
Disneyland as a kid and there's a magic
to it and when you get to the age where
you know the princess is just a Hooters
girl and you see like the human under
you see the glue of the wig you see
Madera or whoever trying to do the the
Irish accent and you're like that's not
Irish but if I the kids are
but we all kind of feel bad for you no I
know the magic is always there for me
you see the invisaline on jasine I don't
want to see no I don't want to believe
it you're not like weren't you my
hostess a katana last night wait a
minute I sleep with you and my wife I
was done with Disney about six seven
years ago I like I've done was enough
and and I thought it was sort of hurting
my career like not giving me legitimacy
because I was this Disney adult known as
a Disney adult yeah and then I then I
went to dinner with Kimmel and I brought
Rickles and he brought Brian Gosling and
Brian was like I love Disney and I'm so
you love Disney too I love it I go there
and I play I said okay he if it's okay
you know it's punk rock but um but what
happened
like would you go to Universal Studios
yes I went to Universal Studios in
Florida dude it was like being on crack
why yeah well what they do is they've
got like all of the cards like you have
like a magnetic thing and you it's just
a very well oiled machine you put your
in the locker and you get on the thing
and it's all Super 3D like it's like
being in a video game it's like being a
simulation that's pretty cool there we
were just there I there no kids really
it's not kids there's some yeah I played
there with the Beach Boys a couple times
at the UN we I was just there but um I'm
a Disney guy I'm going to be there the
first week of December when you have
your little child so but also aren't
Disney movies kind of traumatic for kids
I remember Bambi and all these movies
being very upsetting yeah what was your
first success was it was it the roast I
think it was I think it was being on the
Joan Rivers roast that was the first
time I got to be a roaster she
was she yeah pretty much did you do
there's a documentary oh you were in the
documentary the documentary Geraldo like
the roast was in it but Geraldo is I
think the one that they featured oh I
mean the jokes that I said about her
were like rough rough rough rough and
and for hers yeah like I literally said
my first joke for Joan was Joan I loved
you in the
wrestler it just come out like Joan's
supposed to be ass sold it has a
separate entrance for Black Cox and she
had just gotten so much work done you
know she got all this Botox and I mean I
don't have to tell you everyone starts
laughing based on how much the person
being roasted is laughing so they would
look to her but she kind of like her
face so she would be like I'm laughing
she had to subtitle subtitle her face
she'd be like where fine it was so tight
when she sat down her mouth open and you
think she was laughing do you remember
cla's leechman on there yes the wooden I
remember we were trying to get a wooden
dildo built because she wanted to have
like a wooden dildo with like she was
the best right she had the greatest do
you remember she said uh she said I'm
not here to to roast Bob sagot I'm here
to fuck
John and I went up and give her a kiss
and and then like a couple weeks later I
I had a birthday it was my birthday and
she shows up about midnight 1:00 and wet
hair like she just got out of the shower
and she was so fucking G sang with us
and say happy birthday pictures of her
like flipping my mom off and animal she
was animal animal I love like throwing
in women like that like one of my
favorite jokes ever was uh on the
Shatner roast when um Betty White uh
Betty White
uh what's his name Alexander Jason
Alexander introduces Betty White and
Betty White just goes thank you everyone
everyone ladies and gentlemen Jason
Alexander you know Jason they make 2%
milk
now it's just like what was it someone
had a joke about some Betty suon Shatner
pants Oh God Shatner all right y'all
here's the thing I have a child coming
uh but I'm in a nightmare because I want
to put photos of said vampire I want to
put him around the house you know and I
didn't know how I what am I going to
Kinkos what are we doing I don't even
know I I'm like we're printing photos
I'm texting them to my printer I'm
trying to figure out how to get them out
it's a mess okay remember when I mean
look we used to take a roll of film and
give it to some guy and leave it there
for like a week and they'd be like come
back between 11 and
two next month you're like huh
what you'd like have to park at the mall
and like go to a kiosk to get like am I
going to kiosk to get F I guess I have
no photos of this kid I guess this kid
is going to just be a ghost but even if
I do find a frame by some
miracle and print a photo by a second
miracle I can't decide which photo I
want it's like you know when you see
like a frame photo and you're like this
one again like that was just there
yesterday like like and then if you want
to change you have to go in to the
there's like those little things and you
got to pull it out and you have got it's
just like I can't believe we were doing
that for so long okay thank God for the
Skylight digital picture frame the
Skylight frame is a frame that has any
photos you want in it and all you have
to do is email that photo from your
photo liary straight to the frame at any
time it's genius I'm so mad I didn't
think of this product instead of looking
back through a camera roll you can
display photos of the family in real
time so that your family's not looking
at your phone and seeing those other
folders no one should be seeing this is
the best thing to give any new parent it
will give them constant Joy because they
can't you can't pick just one photo you
know when someone's like look at my baby
and they have to show you 50 photos of
the same baby at the same with the same
hat and the same but to them it's
different I'm going to be that person
too that's just what happens so that's
why I have one of these so that when
other people take pictures of my kid
when they come over they can just email
the photo right to the frame so I don't
have to give my friends my
number you know they're like I'll text
you this picture I'm like I know what
you're doing so this is genius all you
do is email the photo right to this
Frame okay we're not starting a shared
folder we're not there's no Dropbox
there's no zip file involved never again
Skylight is a touchscreen photo frame
that you can send photos to straight
from your phone and they appear in
seconds you can even preload photos
before the box is opened so when it's on
unw wrapped and plugged in your most
Treasured Memories will appear H you're
going to win Christmas with this thing
it is the perfect gift for everyone look
at this so easy to use setup takes
literally less than 60 seconds we did it
right here the touchcreen makes it easy
swipe through the photos tap to see new
photos scent tap the heart if you want
to say thank you they've got black white
silver limited edition poppy it's like
an orangey red and gold frames this is
so much better than social media it's a
great private way to share photos
without posting it to the world
especially for parents who don't always
want photos of their children everywhere
there's a couple of us out there
satisfaction is guaranteed we're
confident that you'll love Skylight we
offer free
120-day returns as a special limited
time offer for our listeners get $15 off
your purchase of a skylight frame when
you go to skylightframe.com
Whitney get $15 off your purchase of a
skylight frame skylightframe.com Whitney
that's Skylight SK y l i g HT f r m /
Whitney funlove.com is a leading online
retailer of sexual health and wellness
products offering the widest selection
of Premier brands of toys lingerie and
accessories they have everything from
soft and sexy to hot and spicy to deep
and juicy I added that I added those too
don't blame the brand that was me sorry
if that was a bummer go indulge and find
Unforgettable presents and gifts for
people on your list at funlove.com
Discover the Allure of intrigue intimate
products a collection of Premiere his
hers and couples toys exclusively
available at funlove.com you can't find
them anywhere else besides my bedside
drawer but you can't buy those I will
never sell them they live with me now
the collection of intrigue has something
to satisfy every person and desire each
toy has sleek and playful Design
Elements and multiple features and
functions browse a wide variety of
vibrators beads bullets rabbits G-spot
toys buildo massages body wands and
bondage kits and find whatever tickles
you fancy Intrigue intimate products are
only available at funlove.com for a
limited time receive 50% off fun Love's
exclusive Intrigue collection when you
enter code good for you at funlove.com
again enter code good for you all one
word receive 50% that's half off
Intrigue funlove.com you know and Bob
this is very sad I don't know
but about a year before he died there
was some jackass kid who got a hold of
stuff put it out of context and did this
whole thing about Bob
and sex with the old like just terrible
shit and but no but it and then it went
super viral on it like something like
they're too old for me or before they
were I had texted them before they were
famous Bob's J it's a brilliant joke
yeah there was a lot of those jokes or
he would just talk about you know U um
someone was just telling said he I think
Santino was talking about that he was
doing a stand up and talking about
having sex with him but this guy this
kid put this thing together and it and
it all a sudden it blew up on Tik Tok
and yeah he raped the OLS and Twins and
it killed him obviously he got it taken
mostly taken down the lawyers got in
there and stuff but it it just and we
but Dave and I were getting getting it
too and how could you be friends with
now the ulton twins showed up at his
funeral as you saw they were so
beautiful I you know we hadn't seen them
in a while the rest of the cast and they
came up and said you know we love you
and you made our childhood great we love
being on the show with you they said all
the things that we like I they gave you
the benad drill yeah was when you were a
baby but okay that's why you guys stayed
so short but okay do you know them I
don't know them personally no but I have
given them a lot of my money for their
fashion line good stuff they have really
good taste uh we one of the nights of
Bob s's thing Chappelle and Jeff Ross
and Dave back at the store right yeah
well there was that but then we also
went back to the guys house that night
remember after the Memorial yeah yeah
that that uh Chappelle and and but one
of my favorite moments actually was one
of his daughters talking about um which
I I mean one of my favorite things about
Bob like obviously the funniest but
whenever I'd hang out with him he would
just tell me how proud he was of his
daughters and what they were doing and
what they were up to and like no one saw
that side he never left anything on the
table I bet you look at your last text
from him and it's I love you I care
about you it will make me it'll kill me
it'll kill me because it's actually me
not him asking me to do his podcast and
me not responding
did you ever do it I never got to do it
because it was during the pandemic and
we were doing all these fundraisers
together remember when we were doing all
these like fundraisers I don't know
where all the money went I don't think
it went anywhere you talking about the
the claraderma stuff no like we were
just doing it like fun fundraising for
like waitresses at The Comedy Store like
comedy gives back like we were just like
doing all these like pandemic
fundraisers and I would always make fun
of him because I feel like he would
always do the zoom fundraiser in the
shest room of his house right do you
know what I mean he'd like go down to
the garage to like look poor in the like
video something I'm like why are we
pretending this is your house but like
what room is this and um but he uh uh I
just loved hearing this from his do
which I don't know how his daughters
were so composed uh at the memorial
because it was like three days later but
um one of them was talking about how in
public whenever he would like see like
another man he would say to her like I
mean look what if like he was your
dad it's just like a funny it's such a
funny thing to like troll your daughter
about like you know he could be your dad
like that guy was your dad he worked so
hard at the and you know he had one of
his daughters was is dealing with some
mental some health issues and you know I
think he he had Co and I think he went
out too soon and he you know that wasn't
great for him yeah and he was you know
it was a lot of money and he and he felt
underwater and he just had to work but
he was also at his Peak you you remember
the last uh post that he did he was like
um I feel like I'm 20 again he was on
stage for two hours and I I just like I
sort of thought about
him just driving home and he he called
his wife Kelly who he loved so much at
the funeral going so Bob still doesn't
know what I do for a
living did you you didn't show up I
think you had Co but we did this thing
at The Comedy Store yeah that one I Mike
binder produced it and stuff and and um
but uh Kelly was walking up and Jim
Carrey goes keep it
short thing so so he but he was I
talking about the uh the he was at the
top of his game and then started touring
and he called Kell and said uh I want to
post this picture and can you can you
you know can you FaceTime tune it and
make me look more handsome and she said
you don't need it Bob you look so
handsome and then I mean this is just in
my mind and then he goes to the to the
um the hotel and he lays down and he and
he he's dreaming about the next time he
sees all of us me and you and his
daughters and kids and family and then
and he's and he's got this smile on his
face because he just just slay an
audience for two hours and and he just
goes to bed with that thought that he
that he just did this incredible two
hours and made a lot of people laugh a
lot of people happy and then
gone it just never ended with him either
it was like it's just he couldn't he had
to make everyone I mean even walking
down the hallway he just had to make
everyone laugh all the time he addicted
I always worried about I was always like
aren't you exhausted like aren't you he
was exhausted yeah and that was the
problem on the show too because he
wasn't getting a lot of laughs as the
character and Dave and I quickly found
that we could be funny together and I
quickly saw that that the Jesse and
Michelle is was going to be a big thing
so he wasn't part of any of that so and
he was like a drug addict for Laughs you
you see people he had accommodated
Tourette it's like Tourette's yep and he
couldn't he it was too much and it was
disruptive for me because he all because
he wasn't getting the laughs on the show
so he was trying to make the crew laugh
all the time you know I said put that in
the show man and he was the only guy who
had hit two daughters at the time then
three and but he was a genius and and
just to see the reaction when he passed
away we went to this we had this great
the four of us had this great dinner at
noobu and it was the last time I saw him
and and we did the cake cock jokes and
you all this stuff and it was like we've
been losing a lot of people it was like
a national heartbreak yeah right it was
like a national heartbreak because it
was also even though he was like such a
goofy silly ass Goose like though I
remember like the episode where can't um
DJ had like an exercise disorder working
out or whatever and like when he would
sit her down on the bed like I didn't
have a dad like raising me you know like
those little talks like meant a lot to
me wow that's so like like people really
um yeah that meant a lot to a lot of
people that's beautiful I it took me
Jeff Franklin was over a couple weeks
ago and he's writing a book and he asked
me he said when did you finally come to
terms with full house because I I you
know took me a long time I said Not
until I wrote this book I don't know
about when you wrote I'm fine but like
did you did you just discover your story
as you're writing it right mine was like
I think a little bit different like I
you know I don't think I was as
self-aware when I wrote my book I kind
of was like okay here's all the like
stories and stuff that I'm too
embarrassed to tell on stage all the
like material I've been trying to figure
out how to make funny but I just don't
know how and I'm just going to basically
tell all my secrets I had just gotten
into a 12ep program how long ago was it
um that
was six years ago oh really I I worked
my ass off revealed everything and then
it came out I've been hair and makeup
about to go on the Today's Show and it
was the day of the Vegas shooting
the book came out so it was like
okay I'm back and I'm the victim in that
scenario it was really hard on me so
just kind of like it's just like having
a book come out you know I mean yours
has gone so smoothly like so God I
locked out though because right when I
finished all the Press there well first
of all you know it was we couldn't book
the shows because everybody was on
strike we didn't know if that was then
they went back and then you know nobody
could promote their movies but this is
different so that worked and then that
there was that there was that shooting
in in um in Maine right into the thing
and um but you do pour your like it's
been really weird like How Deeply you
went like it's sort of like I mean I'm
in a 12ep program also like to be able
to just like like expunge all this from
like all like we're only as sick as the
secrets we keep and I feel like we carry
around our own Secrets other people's
Secrets like writing a book you just get
to like get it out but I didn't want to
at first I didn't I didn't want to write
a book period I didn't think I was smart
enough I didn't think I could do it I I
just didn't have it I thought I'm not
going to talk about who I and that's all
anybody cares about which is bullshit
that's not true and so I kept saying no
no no then I was a dad at 55 okay that's
interesting and then Bob died and they
said they saw this um they read the
thing I did for the LA Times the AG said
you're a good writer I said I don't
remember even writing that well why
don't you write they brought an offer I
said no I'm not and then I had these
beautiful notes from my mother
but I didn't want to be so honest and I
set out was like I'm GNA write a hero
story I did this and I did that and I
was like this is you know and I got I
they said well the publisher said you
got to write about your ex-wife Rebecca
and I said no I don't said it's you know
part of your story so I finally I wrote
that early on and I wrote about being in
rehab and do through the 12 steps and
four fourth step was you know write all
your resentments down I had the sponsor
and he said write every you know make a
call them and write I said she did this
to me and she did that she did and he
said are you done I said no take another
paper give me another pen said okay good
uh now in the next column write what
part you played in all all that I go I
don't I didn't it goes even if it was 1%
just just write it down I started
writing and writing oh fuck man I had a
lot as much to do with with the demise
of our relationship than than I than as
her and that I thought which is like the
miracle of the program because like At
first you're like wait a second like I
now I have to feel bad I have to feel
guilty or someone harm me but it's like
the freedom that comes with going like
oh I can own that part and then the
shame dissipates but it's also like then
you have a monum of control
so it's like oh if I had a part in that
that means I don't have to repeat that
that do toen to me I get to change
instead of like I'm a victim I think a
lot of people want to be a victim but
this amazing thing happens when you go
like oh no that was my fault there's
something so freeing about it yes and
you think it's not going to be freeing
you think I got to keep this too I can't
I can't admit it oh you didn't even you
can't even feel that you did but then
when you open up and I came across this
line that I wrote I'm so relieved when
something's my fault yeah me too I say
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm so sorry I am so
now I get to own this but now I don't
feel like being bullied by the world
anymore and then I'm not in control and
I'm this victim you know cuz otherwise
it's it's like I mean my program is like
I'm perfect and everybody has hurt me
and you know but then you're kind of
like oh no I stayed too long like you
can always find aing way that you had a
part I stayed too long I tried to fix
the person I I tried to you know get my
internal needs met externally I tried
too hard to make something work I tried
to control the person like there's
always going to be something that's
right I lied to myself whatever it is
for sure it's a that deep dark secret
that you look into I came across this
line and then I that I stayed with that
the whole time which was uh anything
less than the truth is
paralysis that a good one I don't know
where it came from and I just wrote it
and then I then then I went back and
sort of told the truth about a lot of it
um and then it was hard because I don't
I don't I'm a pleaser too right I want
everybody to be happy with me and
everybody to love me and stuff which is
the number one way to not please anyone
cuz nothing's more annoying than a
people pleaser yeah are you okay are you
fine are you fine happy is just like G
the most annoying energy yeah and I yes
I try to you know work that but um I
when the like I think it was on a
Wednesday like they started picking all
the the salacious stuff out I caught my
I was madly in love with this guy named
Terry Copley and I caught her in bed
with with Tony Dan yeah is that who it
is wasn't it was that it yeah yeah and
the only reason why I put that in there
was because the the the the um the end
of the story was that Full House came
out the first season and did didn't do
well and at the very end they said we're
going to we're probably going to cancel
you but we're going to try one thing in
the summer we're going to put you on one
of our after one of our hit shows summer
reruns and if you get an audience then
we'll think about picking you up and the
show was who's the boss so I was like
okay right but um why not I'm so done
keeping everybody's Secrets I know but
it you know yes and I really didn't take
it you want me to write better about you
you should have behaved better well that
was it but I went to bed crying one
night I was like oh there people you
know he was upset I gu has and I thought
that my I thought Rebecca had have seen
the video of him roller skating into a
pole in New York City no into a what he
roller skates into a pole in New York
City remember when Tony Dana had a talk
show for a minute I was on
it I love I was shocked that he had me
on there because of this you know this
thing that happened a few years earlier
he was like if I get him on I'll never
write about this in a book yeah well I'm
sure he whatever but I felt bad about
that and then I thought Rebecca had said
something and I I felt bad about that
turns out she didn't it was the husband
said some something innocuous nothing
bad yeah yeah and then I just went I
just felt so crappy and you over the
years you probably dealt with cuz you
guys with the roasts and with your
comedy you make fun of people have you
had people call you out on or call you
up and go why you know what was the
roughest actually and I recently um and
you're talking about it right now like
you're already repairing you're already
going like a I maybe shouldn't have done
that or maybe I shouldn't have written
about that or maybe I should whatever no
I didn't say that the well but I was
fine writing it but I felt anyway the
roast of David Hasselhoff
Pam Anderson was on it and Pam Anderson
had had her own roast yeah I saw she was
the in the throne right so now she's
just on the hassle H what did Gilbert
what did they say don't it was right
after 911 one of those um was it like
Gilbert don't say 911 don't well there's
always like rules in each roast right
for I mean Pam Anderson and Tommy Lee it
was the kid that drowned in the pool
Shatner was the woman that drowned in
the pool someone's always drowned in
something his wife didn't his wife drown
pool and then Jo Rivers was Melissa her
daughter um uh David Hasselhoff Hulk
Hogan's daughter was off limits um and
then maybe Hasselhoff so what was the
thing with Hasselhoff and then Trump was
literally nothing um oh God so this was
on Hasselhoff roast pamy Anderson's
there this is my second roast they're
paying me $5,000 she's getting
$500,000 I'm like this is Pam Anderson
what and you know like people sometimes
drop out the day the day before on
remember what's that Arty Lang remember
Arty okay that was Saget's roast so we
had written all these jokes about Arty
Lang yes they were fat jokes the day
before he's attempts suicide can't make
it we have all these jokes and we're
just like what we just need a fat we
scrambled for fat we go for like Louis
Anderson we're Patrice O'Neil and then
and then we get Jeff Garland who's not
he's literally lost
why did you lose so much weight why no
every joke is like literally look at
that bean bag chair over there oh no
that's Jeff car like we switched that to
Jeff Ross I had some great jokes about
Arty too damn it yeah so I'm sorry
sidetracked always like fall in fall out
I mean Mike Tyson was on it falls out so
by the time we shoot it like I have five
pages of Pam Anderson jokes but like a
bunch of people had like popped out and
uh I went pretty hard I mean I literally
said um uh Pam Anderson you've dated
Tommy
Kid Rock and Brett Michaels why don't
you just save yourself some time and
drink a vat of Magic Johnson's
blood like it was like it was like that
it was like you had I remember that joke
who said did you say that joke I said
that yeah when was the what was the
first one you were on cuz I don't think
J Rivers okay was that the first one I
wrote on was Flavor Flav Flavor Flav
then Bob cuz they hired me because I
sent in a whole packet and they wanted
to use one of my jokes they always said
they'll never hire a female writer they
have the same Five Guys it's never going
to happen I wrote like 16 pages of joke
for flavor flave and I wrote the joke
flave you look like what Magic Johnson
should look like right now so they
brought me in for the week so they could
use that and then I had to like fight
too and nail to kind of like stay in the
in the ring and then you became the the
the king chili cheese over there so but
wait so Joe Rivers so pamy Anderson so
she's I'm going pretty hard at her and
then she's I can tell she's upset she
gets up she Le like comes back a hassle
off one H one yeah her was
I think also but she had Tommy there and
she was like kind of I don't know in a
different head space like before the
show she was like you know my kids are
going to watch this and I'm like bitch
yeah this is I don't know what to tell
you man like I'm just I'm here to win I
have $40,000 worth of loans I have no
credit like this is were these were
these college recently apologized to her
um and I like you become a
mother see how much guilt you have
then this show is brought to you by
Dreamland baby maker of the famous dream
weighted sleep sack I'm holding it up
it's a GameChanger so you know I'm fully
pregnant at the moment and I've had most
of my friends tell me that the key to
getting babies to actually sleep is this
weighted sleep sack the ones who didn't
recommend it in all fairness recommended
Whiskey on the gum so let's just ignore
the people that didn't recommend it I've
used a weighted blankets for myself to
fall asleep so it makes total sense that
a stressed out little tot would do well
with this soft AF lightly weighted sleep
sack that makes them feel like they're
right back in the womb because my womb
is probably this exact blue
color and quilted frankly grab a
Dreamland baby weighted sleepsack to get
deeper sleep for you and your baby the
product is genius it is so genius you've
seen it on Shark Tank folks it's easy to
use it has a 2-way zipper for fuss free
diaper changes and cover com technology
evenly distributed weight from the
shoulders to the toes look at that
Dreamland baby sleep sack you're going
to save so much time that by not having
to you know cool them and sound machines
and all that time that you save you can
use to cry in your car and try to figure
out how to you know cut their tiny
little nails and you can wash the poop
off everything you care about and
furiously check Tik Tok for parenting
advice and for pediatricians who will
respond to a DM in under four hours
you're going to have so much time freed
up if you go to
dreamland.com enter my code Whitney at
checkout and receive 20% off sitewide
and free shipping this offer is for new
and existing customers I'm telling you
Dreamland baby sleepsack total Game
Changer go to Dreamland bab code.com my
code Whitney a checkout 20% off can't
say it enough do it this show is brought
to you by betterhelp this is the time of
year you need to get some therapy why
because everybody else won't I promise
you your parents will not be doing
therapy this December and working out
their Character defects before you go
home for the holidays I promise you they
are not studying the Nuance of the
Israel Palestine Hamas situation I
promise they will say something insane
about it I promise you that they will
make a backhand a compliment about your
appearance and ask why you don't have
kids yet or if you do have kids they'll
say something to the child that will
destroy the child's self-esteem for life
I am willing to bet money that I am
right about this we cannot force our
family members to go to therapy but if
we go we can at least have some tools to
be able to either shut up or as they
call it in therapy set boundaries or you
can tell them to go f themselves or as I
learned in therapy have the Dignity of
their own experience I've learned so
much in therapy about how to protect
myself around the holidays to not feel
guilty and pressure to go to every
holiday thing it's an amazing tool is
when you tell tell someone ahead of time
a therapist told me this that you can
say I can come by from 1: to 3: like
give them a window ahead of time so you
don't go at 1 and then start packing up
at 2:45 and they're like you're leaving
you just got here and then they try to
guilt you into staying to watch them get
drunker and drunker and handier and
handier great tool that I got from
therapy so you should try it too it's
just full of tools put some more Tools
in your tool box this holiday season if
you're thinking about starting therapy
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your seual as
they say in London Town just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get match with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge
find your bright spot this season with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com Whitney
toay and get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp.com
Whitney who do you feel like should have
been a bigger comic Yannis papus yeah no
I don't mean that that's not funny I
mean I mean that in the in a way like
why isn't he more successful and I I
talk about that he should be playing by
the way he's one of the funniest people
he's one of the funniest he said he
would he stayed with you a couple times
here he had he said how was it I said
well they're dog fights yes and he's
dating some she's dating some guy and he
you know he got in the middle of a dog
fight he came to my house remember and
he I don't think he wanted to leave my
house to come back here he is literally
one of the funniest people on the planet
are we calling him I'm trying to call
him I love him so much we're just
curious John would like to
know why you're not more famous I would
like to know why he's naked he's
literally who are you ber cry Shir why
you why your why don't you have a shirt
on now I will be okay Bird that's the
that's why you you need a gimmick you go
out with your chesticles just hanging
out just did balls yanis is my favorite
you know I I I stumbled upon him on on
in I think and he was doing jokes about
me but they were nice cuz we're Greek
and is that what happened and I dm'd you
or something that's correct yeah that's
exactly what did you cuz you call
yourself retarded John Samos yeah it was
special
need but then he was saying the nicest
stuff about me and then we we connected
the first time we saw each other I think
in person you were staying here at
Whitney's what what room did he stay in
should we go look at he was right next
door her yeah I said he saved my life he
broke up a pit fight all right yeah she
was I the only thing that was available
was a kennel I was sleeping with dogs
the whole
place people there that like I don't
even think she knows is there I met I me
people I go there and I'm like hey I'm
like you know what they're like no we
just heard that she just lets you live
here she didn't live here she was
there's just people in my house I've
never met well I think he was and then
you were came to my house and you're
like please let me stay here I don't
want to go back to
whitness we did have some amazing Greek
food remember do you remember the name
of that restaurant in tan there's an
amazing Greek place co-signed by Giannis
papus yeah it was really good that was a
fun night and um yeah I don't remember
the name of it though but have you ever
seen Giannis watch football I've never
watched football oh watching him watch
football is what most people watching
football feels like like what it's very
fun to watch I love John Stamos America
loves JN stos everyone needs to get this
book right away but I also said this is
the biggest compliment it's like how is
Giannis not the biggest comedian of all
time 100% a compliment and I I ask
everybody because it's like when is it
going to be his turn I just want from
insiders like you and they all say he's
very close and he's just got to get
funny the only problem is is he's not
funny so when he gets that I want to see
Giannis get his next big step and he
will soon because we love him he's so
funny the funniest are you masturbating
what are you doing like wait show show
us your hands D is this how you sleep on
your side yeah I sleep on my slide
blankies with my
blank Teddy and my sexy you know uh
mouthpiece that's not Invisalign it's
just like a sleep apnea thing yeah it
pulls your jaw forward so you don't
snore but is the idea what's wrong with
snoring it's just your wife will leave
you no well yeah and I I have sleep
apnea but medium not extreme so hey look
at have you why see look how beautiful
Whitney is look just show them she looks
actually looks Inc you look incredible
she looks like Angelina Jolie you know
what the the best and worst thing I ever
did was dye my hair blue because having
blue and purple and orange up hair and I
look like Courtney Love for a while and
now people like you look amazing I just
set the bar so low for
myself no you've always been hot but you
look you look like a woman like a back
Brown what you say it's almost like God
knew matched my face you've always been
hot you weren't into the like fullon
meth head no but you're you've grown
into a woman now a like a beautiful
woman excuse us I'm not wrong excuse us
I'm not kissing your ass because it took
you know you probably need someone to
take care of that kid so hope I'll be
good I'm good you see me on on the TV
show at the end Michelle don't eat that
lizard you know whatever it may you have
you have friends take care of your dogs
when you're away who's gonna take care
of the kid when you are away Miss Pat is
taking the
child yeah we love you love you love you
too wrong number what is it with Greek
people I I've never met a Greek person I
don't get along with really that I don't
like Rita Wilson do you know reader are
you guys friends what not being funny
she's one of my best friends Oh I
thought you gonna say like like I'm like
I get along with all green people youlon
yeah Jen Aniston alexop I have a lot of
friends Hannah stocking a lot of my
friends are Greek Hannah stocking she's
a big
influencer um Alex theopus Chef um and
comedian galanakis do you know exactly I
don't I've never met a Greek person that
I don't like that's good what's that
great what's the ancestral trauma none
salad no the salad's kind of suck
as oh yes that what it is that's why
that was big back then what do you mean
back then it's uh it's back when I've
never ancient Greece oh you haven't I
was there this summer so great yeah MOS
I no I didn't go there uh we uh Athens
you have to go to Athens first and then
there's this island that Rita has a
place there Nia was there okay all the
famous Greeks and um Jim genopis do you
know Jim
from uh and they've been asking me to go
for the longest time so I went for my
birthday and it was really great oh fun
this leads into I I I've had all these
great mentors over over and now you're
I'm sure you're mentoring these young
Comics coming up and stuff right no I TR
I do the best I can here's I do the best
I can but I also go look the way what I
did to make it that path no longer
exists right so so they need mentors you
might need to just become a Tik Tok star
or make a sex tape or get on a reality
show I don't know because I did it like
hard yes I went on Leno and then I
worked really hard to get five minutes
from Montreal and then I built th those
days are over so I don't know maybe you
need to be live streaming your butthole
on YouTube I just am not sure but you're
like the the grand D of you're not old
but I like call no no well you're
pregnant um remember we did the um Bob
and I flew in to do some New Year's Eve
TV what was that what was that was it
Rock and Eve or something no no no no it
was a game show or something oh I think
I know with Andy Cohen yes yes and uh
yeah and you were sitting next to me
braw I was like what what you doing I
was
like I'm I'm get I'm getting wrecked I
think I was newly sober I was like
stop um but you are the like the but
you're like the the the boss of of you
know like who create you created two
show you created your show and then and
then two two drunk girl two girls and
two drunk girls chela Handler Story how
about that it is what how about it how
many years did that go that went for
almost seven years yeah you must be Rich
As Fuck no my family has made sure that
I am dirt poor your your family's dead
yeah what but they stayed alive for a
really long time in very expensive
nursing homes and icus with no health
insurance which kind like they were in
um uh uh Georgia and my mom actually
moved out here to Eno did she live with
you no she was in a nursing home close
by but it's you know caretakers and then
in and out of icus the whole thing but I
think on some level like like making
money spending it all on my family the
codependence of it all kept me in a
state of needing to work and I think
that that was probably a good thing for
me like I still have to work for money
where are you at now what do you what
what's your next move next Mo having
special come out in two weeks and then
um just did those two rasts I think
we're going to do more row Loop you into
it the Bert and who else for me oh
there's the roast of did they air
already Yes on only fans TV what the
fuck is that only only fans like only
fans is like there's no nudity only fans
TV is just like free streaming service
it's like cooking shows yeah it's
working and they're actually doing
uncensored comedy they're doing comedy
Like Comics that are like for lack of a
better word like middle class Comics
that are doing remember like evening at
The Improv and stuff like that where
like not if in order to get a Netflix
special you have to be famous you have
to be Tom SAR you have to be bur Cher
whatever but there's all these amazing
Comics that used to be able to get
famous off of doing The Tonight Show or
Letterman or whatever or live at Gotham
comic Central is kind of gone so it's
like they have nowhere to go except
their own Tik Tok or Instagram but how
are you going to amplify so they're able
to do their sets on here they're doing
these amazing like specials I did two
roasts on there and then I'm doing their
first standup special oh that's great
and totally did you shoot it already
shot it a month ago is it great it's
great do you edit do you have by now you
you you're calling the shots with right
do what what what um do you are you
helping young Comics like your boy
Rodney did yeah take them on the road
you know what dangerfields was actually
up for lease what's that mean the comedy
club in New York where is oh in New York
yeah did you get it no I thought about
it let's also Rogan kind of opened this
comedy he did open this Comedy Club are
you friends are you guys I don't I don't
I've never met
I'm a fan you love him you get along for
him to do what he's done in this in this
scene what a great thing huh you he's
also your comedy nerd he loves a comedy
nerd like for like for real did you meet
reckles did you ever know reckles I went
to his I mean just giant fan I went to
his toast remember did you go to that in
New York the do toast the the friers
thing that was at the friar yeah and it
was I remember cuz Joan Rivers yeah
right yeah remember she was there but
the idea is it wasn't a roast it was a
toast and everyone was just kind of
being nice his daughter does stand up
yeah Mindy yeah I've gone to see her I
was standing in line I was getting ready
to go on stage and dairo was in front of
me or back of me and and we'd gone to um
Iraq together and for some reason they
stuck me with USO thing yeah was oh wow
no we went to fight
I went to the sandals I yeah the S all
inclusive Iraq that was maybe that was
why it didn't work out with Rebecca
should not have honeymoon there that was
beautiful was that Waldorf or something
that's exactly some in New York I just
remember because I was sitting next to
Katy Perry I guess there was like the
weird like I don't know I was at some
weird table Katy Perry and I had gotten
my nails done for this which I never do
and I got them
gray with like a little neon green as
the tip which is like kind of a crazy
Choice whatever and I'm sitting next to
Katy Perry who's Lovely by the way she
wasn't I don't think she was trying to
be rude well she got she shoots
fireworks shots of her cupcake tits and
she goes I love your nails and I was
like thank you and she went Ikea
colors I was
like she real Don didn't know he was the
king of it you know I mean this from my
heart you're going nowhere whatever you
know schmuck and I think I heard Sarah
maybe you or Sarah Silverman used the
term and I remember I used to tell him
man you're the king of schmuck what's
that what you do all day long I don't do
schmuck bait do you know that term yes
but also I also I'm I lied to you I
think actually Rickles did the quent and
Tarantino Fri Club Roast that didn't air
and that's the first roast I ever ever
did were you just you were on it I was
just on it as a performer how many did
you do then after I did well I did as a
performer that one after I had written
on a couple ones and then I did three I
did Trump Joan Rivers and uh David
Hasselhoff and then I took a little
break did you ever get to the Hasselhoff
thing that that we were talking about
that you that he got upset about oh was
Anderson yeah yeah Hoff was like great I
mean Trump was actually the wildest
because Trump after destroying him for
like 18 minutes I came off and I just
went hey I'm so you know you like Apollo
you're kind of like sorry he went that
was great television wow what about the
pilot that you didn't hire me for uh
remember this one I really wanted this
pilot it's the great this HBO pilot the
greatest fucking script I I've ever read
it pilot wise and it's all and it's I
wanted it so bad I know this is the one
I with Le Daniels who Lee Daniels it was
the one about the college campus yeah
and and and you and hired what's his
name from um Greer and how was that I
love that that's the credit you give
[Applause]
him I'm sure he's no I don't have
anything say no I just wrote um like an
animated movie um and now I'm kind of
like now that the strike is over and I
just like was worried about TV I feel
like TV was in a weird place I feel like
the two best things I've ever written
didn't end up going I did this one thing
in HBO and this other thing that was
about the like basically human resources
department in a college
campus it was three generations of women
trying to figure out like your girls are
like he assaulted me and was like that's
just a date I was kind of in the middle
and the young girl is like he has to be
can you know it was like I all you know
and trying to navigate all this new like
woke stuff on a college campus and um
didn't go at Amazon which by the way I
don't know it's weird like we're doing
shows for grocery stores now I mean it's
Amazon I don't know I'm getting notes
from a grocery store I did I did one for
Amazon to I had this I had this show at
Netflix that that um and I always did
you watch California obsessed Tom Campos
genius so I went after him to do the
show and we're doing it but um it's the
it's like I'm Tech ail oh yeah yeah yeah
it's four guys like your show but it's
like they no offense but they
overdeveloped for women out there and
and it was just like this it was like a
male it's it's like a male big little
eyes that's awesome it's about um have
you been to Hidden Hills where I I live
I have slept outside your house many
times oh that's right that was you I
looked around we moved in there and I go
it's so beautiful shiny streets and
everything's perfect and there's a
there's a lawn and there's a horse
I go there's some bullshit going on I'm
find out what it is and I did and so
that's that like Desperate House
Husbands Z yeah but a little more Tom
Camp you know well because it is also
all of these guys like you that have
seen it all done it all and are now
settled down and like God knows what
skeletons are going to like pop out of
the closet right the bigger the closet
the more the
skeletons so you're so you yeah do you
feel like you need to write it oh you
wrote it animations I do voices by the
way in case oh yeah you listen to my
audio it's
this that IP it's of Frank probably like
like it this was on every folder like
growing up like when I was in like
school I don't think I'm the I don't
think I'm not a colorful tiger guy yeah
but you could be like a which like a
horse Ain or a I'm a penguin you could
be like the Greek chicken hi I'm a Greek
chicken I know like a fuck me in the
ass what are what are there Anime
animals in Gree like a sardine
yeah I love that idea that's genius oh
yeah but I get I get a little bit like
paralysis because it's like it's almost
like choosing a husband or like a wife
It's like because if I do this show I'll
be doing this for eight years if you're
idea I show went eight years right
probably Big Bang Theory yeah that long
are you friends with all those yeah but
those are that was start that was a
while ago yeah yeah yeah no I know it's
probably and also they do 13 episodes
right thing don't be afraid I know you
that we should do a show together let's
do it we should do The Odd Couple on bro
not Broadway but like dinner theater
kind of like travel with it I feel like
the have you done something like that
dinner theater no well any theater play
musical not a ton did you do your audio
book gosh I did my Audi book and I was
reading it like as if I hadn't written
it it was so hard like so hard it is so
hard to read your own audio but because
I'm also like trying to change things as
I go so so I had enough time that's
exactly happen with me and I'm reading
it for and you're reading you're cold
reading your life right yeah and you're
like be funnier and then I'm like I'm
being corny and I'm like I need to
delete this I just repeated the same
word like I like you guys thing about
you guys didn't catch this typo like I
was just so in my head and then a friend
of mine was like you just need to take
an Aderall and get in there and do it I
take an Aderall I can't even speak I'm
like cleaning the thing I'm like I'm
like you guys can we just move the the
composer stand like I can't focus on
doing it so then I had to cancel it my
my out started getting all cottonon dry
yeah I just was like a mess I they said
oh I'll take about 5 days I took 37 Days
K it's like in um when you're in a 12st
step meeting and they pass you something
to read and you all of a sudden just
can't read that's how I was I was like
after an hour or so i' be
like what's this word t e like like dear
God we We Gather to and you're just like
this is it's just like and they're just
sitting there but I did it and it took a
long time to do and in fact I said that
I was going to I said I'll pay for the
extra days because I wanted to get it
right because that's all I do is listen
to audiobooks and I do voices and you
know it's it's um it's um it's so weird
it's so surreal this and and and to have
like a I never wanted I never that
wasn't my thing I just but those are
always the best books anyone like it's
like I'm so interesting I need to write
a book it's usually inure people that
have the most interesting to say no and
it's the perfect time yeah I guess so
well now that I'm 0 I love you thank you
for having me and thank you for being
such a like you've always been such a
like light in this business like there's
so many just like creepy weirdos and
spooky corners and you've always just
been like such a bright like shiny
sparkly light and anytime I see you in a
situation I'm always scared and socially
awkward wherever we are and I'm always
like stay most like my safe place yeah
I'll always be your safe place you're
the best just don't have your birthday
on my birthday yeah moving forward it
was like super it was a it was a 60 sexy
that's it it was a costume thing but
then it turned into super sexy super
spreader 30 people got Co no a lot of
your friends were there too I know but
it's good that you didn't go cuz people
got sick and I was preo and was I lost a
baby during this interview yeah oh sorry
let's go thank you everybody love you
love you too don't kill elephants what
is it about elephant don't dry hump El
don't dry hump
El if you would have told me it's out
now it's number four let's make number
one woo that's so
[Music]
crazy